Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. And with me is Dominic Sandbrook. And Dominic, do you remember, we did an interview with GQ about the podcast. And I'm not saying that to boast. Fashion tips. Fashion tips.
谢谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目的抢先收听资格，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的 rest》。我是汤姆·霍兰德，坐在我身边的是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，你还记得吗，我们之前接受过《GQ》杂志关于这个播客的采访。我这么说可不是为了炫耀。时尚建议。时尚建议。
What the well-dressed man in Chipping Norton is wearing. And one of the one of the questions we were asked was uh what fields of history do you know absolutely nothing about yes i do i paid close attention to what you said because i thought that it might prove useful i could store it up and then spring it on you and one of the one of the subjects you mentioned was the history of india yeah you've never been to India. You knew absolutely nothing about it. Well, I've seen Octopussy. And I've also seen Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom.
奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton）那些穿着讲究的人都在穿什么。当时我们被问到的其中一个问题是，嗯，你们对历史的哪些领域是一无所知的？是的，我的确如此，我非常关注你当时说的话，因为我觉得这可能会派上用场，我可以把它记在心里，然后在关键时刻抛出来考考你。你当时提到的其中一个学科就是印度史。对，你从来没去过印度，你对它一无所知。好吧，我看过《八爪女》（Octopussy）。我还看过《印第安纳·琼斯与魔宫传奇》（Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom）。
What else is there to know? And I kind of figured that's kind of it, right? I mean... Okay. So the reason I saved that up is that I'm a massive Indophile. India was the very first
还有什么需要了解的吗？我想大概也就这样了吧？我是说……好吧。我把这个话题留到现在的原因是，我是一个狂热的印度迷。印度是我去的
foreign country I ever went to. The first foreign country? I landed in Bombay, as it then was, and I spent six months there. Doing what? Not playing cricket, surely? I did play cricket there. Yes, I did play cricket there. Yeah, but you didn't go to play cricket, surely?
第一个外国。去过的第一个外国？我在当时的孟买降落，并在那里待了六个月。去干什么？肯定不是去打板球吧？我在那里打过板球。是的，我在那儿打过板球。对，但你总不是为了打板球才去的吧？
I went, because India is so enormous. I mean, it's kind of, it's massive, and everywhere is so interesting. We went there for honeymoon. I've been there actually on two cricket tours. So anyway, I absolutely love it. The producer has sent me a message that says most people went to Benidorm for their first foreign trip. Well, I'd never been to Calais, and I landed in Benidorm.
我是因为印度太大了。我是说，它太广袤了，而且到处都那么有趣。我们去那儿度蜜月。我实际上去过那里进行过两次板球巡回赛。所以无论如何，我是真的非常喜欢它。制作人给我发了一条消息，说大多数人第一次出国旅游都是去贝尼多姆（Benidorm）。好吧，我甚至没去过加来（Calais），我就直接在贝尼多姆降落了。
What a gilded youth you enjoyed. Not at all, because I'd never been abroad. We never had foreign holidays. Oh, it's like the four Yorkshiremen sketch. Yes. Anyway, listen, the last time I went to India, it was with Willie Dalrymple at his amazing literary festival at Jaipur. And in Jaipur, I met the wonderful Aparna Andhare,
你度过了多么优渥的金色青春啊。一点也没有，因为我以前从来没出过国。我们从来没有去过国外度假。哦，这就像那出“四个约克郡人”的小品。是的。不管怎样，听着，我上次去印度是和威利·达尔林普尔（Willie Dalrymple）一起去的，参加他在斋浦尔举办的精彩文学节。在斋浦尔，我遇到了极好的阿帕娜·安达雷（Aparna Andhare），
who was a curator at the museum in Jaipur. And she showed me around it. And I thought, bearing in mind that you know nothing about India, and that we have tried and tested this format with Rachel Morley, with the British churches, where she did basically her top 10 British churches, I thought it would be fun to ask Aparna if she could do the impossible and give us a history of India in 10 buildings. So going right the way from the ancient world,
她曾是斋浦尔博物馆的馆长。她带我参观了那里的博物馆。我想，考虑到你对印度一无所知，而且我们和蕾切尔·莫雷（Rachel Morley）探讨英国的教堂时，已经用过这种经过考验的模式了——当时她基本上讲了她心目中的十大英国教堂——我觉得如果能请阿帕娜来做一件不可能的事，用10座建筑给我们讲讲印度史，应该会很有趣。所以从古代世界一直讲起，
right the way up to the modern. And Aparna, you're joining us. Where are you joining us from? I'm in Bombay. In Bombay. Well, then technically, if you're going to get technical then I live in New Bombay which is now in Mumbai which is outside of Bombay it's a twin city so if you're going to be if you're going to be specific then that's where I am well let's be specific okay so
一直讲到现代。阿帕娜，你加入我们了。你现在是在哪里连线我们？我在孟买。在孟买。好吧，如果你要较真的话，我住在新孟买，它现在属于孟买市，位于孟买市区之外，是一座双子城。所以如果你要具体指出的，那我就是在那里。好吧，那我们就具体一点。好吧，所以
so from New Bombay um and you very bravely and gamely agreed to do this so you've drawn up your list of 10 buildings and And when we say India, we're talking about the Indian subcontinent. So not modern day India. We're including what's now Pakistan, Afghanistan, and so on. Bangladesh. Yes, absolutely. And this wasn't easy, Dom.
从新孟买出发，嗯，你非常勇敢且爽快地答应了这项任务，所以你列出了你的10座建筑清单。当我们说印度时，我们指的是印度次大陆。所以不仅仅是现代的印度，还包括现在的巴基斯坦、阿富汗等等。孟加拉国。是的，完全正确。这可不容易，多姆。
This wasn't easy at all. So I'm glad I'm foolish in that sense. No, your game, your game, your game. Well, we like to set people a challenge, don't we? Yes, we do. The challenge it was. So I live with an architectural historian, and I have to say there were fights over this,
这真的一点也不容易。所以我很高兴我在这方面是个“傻子”。不，你很勇敢，你很配合。好吧，我们喜欢给别人出难题，不是吗？是的，我们确实喜欢。这确实是个挑战。所以，我和一位建筑历史学家生活在一起，我必须说，为了这个我们曾争论过，
about what was important, what was, you know, what was just beautiful. So when we're recounting the history, these are not specifically, so the 10 sites I've chosen, they might not make their cut for being the most beautiful or things that you immediately associate with India, but they're important for the trajectory of Indian history. So no Taj Mahal? Oh, no Taj Mahal, no.
关于什么是重要的，什么是，你知道的，仅仅是美丽的。所以当我们讲述历史时，这些并非专门是——因此我挑选的10个遗址，它们可能不会因为最美丽或者让你立刻联想到印度而入选，但它们对于印度历史的发展轨迹至关重要。所以没有泰姬陵？哦，没有泰姬陵，没有。
No Taj Mahal, okay. Everyone knows the Taj, I mean, it is gorgeous. It is too obvious. It is too obvious, absolutely. Even Dominic's heard of the Taj Mahal. Okay. Everyone knows the Taj. I mean, it is gorgeous. It is too obvious. Even Dominic's heard of the Taj Mahal. Tom is very obvious sometimes. Apparently, you might have noticed. But have you been?
没有泰姬陵，好吧。人人都知道泰姬陵，我的意思是，它美极了。这太显而易见了。这太显而易见了，绝对的。连多米尼克都听说过泰姬陵。好吧。人人都知道泰姬陵。我的意思是，它美极了。这太显而易见了。连多米尼克都听说过泰姬陵。汤姆有时真的很显眼。显然，你可能已经注意到了。但是你去过吗？
Have you been to the Taj? Have I been to Taj Mahal? Yes. Yes, of course. And did you like it? I loved it. Except that we went there for our honeymoon. And my wife was sick over a large number
你去过泰姬陵吗？我去过泰姬陵吗？去过。是的，当然去过。那你喜欢它吗？我很喜欢。除了我们是去那儿度蜜月的。我妻子在印度的许多最具历史意义的建筑上
of India's most historic buildings and the Taj Mahal was one of them. Oh, what a lovely story. The other one is Fatima, sickly. Romantic. Appropriately. She's going to kill me for revealing this. Anyway, let's reverse after this particular conversation
都吐过，泰姬陵就是其中之一。哦，多么可爱的故事。另一个是法蒂玛，病恹恹的。真浪漫。非常应景。她会因为我泄露这个而杀了我。不管怎样，在这场特殊的对话之后，我们还是回归正题吧
of cult attack. Yeah, we've got 10 buildings to get through and we don't want to do a Rachel Morley and leave seven of them to the last five minutes. Okay, so Aparna, what is your first building? Okay, so the first site we'll pick is the Indus Valley Civilization and a site called Mohenjodaro, which means the Mound of the Dead. And this is the high point of Harappan civilization between 2600 to 1900 BCE. I think what is most interesting is the Great Park, which is how every big swimming pool ought to be. It's on top of a citadel and it's got channels around and lots of changing rooms and bathrooms. So it probably was a ritual space and is this fantastic
由于某种崇拜的袭击。是的，我们有10座建筑要讲，我们可不想像蕾切尔·莫雷那样，把其中的7座留到最后五分钟才讲。好的，阿帕娜，你的第一座建筑是什么？好的，我们挑选的第一个遗址是印度河流域文明的一个遗址，叫做摩亨佐达罗（Mohenjodaro），意思是“死者之丘”。这是哈拉帕文明（Harappan civilization）在公元前2600年至公元前1900年间的全盛时期。我认为最有趣的是大浴池（Great Bath），它符合人们对所有大型游泳池的完美想象。它位于卫城顶部，四周有水道，还有大量的更衣室和浴室。所以它可能是一个宗教仪式的场所，而且这是一个非常了不起的
water. It's like a swimming pool, right? So it's got, it uses tar and it uses gypsum plaster. So it's quite watertight and you could probably look all over from it. Now, Harappans or the Indus Valley civilization thrived on trade, it thrived on commerce, and they also basically set up big city and trading outposts. And they had to then move. Why did the Indus civilization fade out? We don't know. But it perhaps was also a direct result of climate change because water had moved out or... So it's getting hotter. I don't know if it was getting hotter, but I think that the river flowed differently. And so does that mean that basically this is a dead end?
水源。它就像一个游泳池，对吧？它采用了焦油和石膏灰泥。所以它的防水性能相当好，你可能可以站在上面俯瞰四周。现在，哈拉帕人或印度河流域文明是以贸易繁荣起来的，它以商业繁荣起来，他们还基本上建立起大型城市和贸易据点。然后他们不得不迁移。为什么印度河文明会消亡？我们不得而知。但这也许也是气候变化直接导致的结果，因为水源枯竭了，或者……所以天气变热了。我不知道天气是否变热了，但我认为河流的流向发生了变化。那么这是否意味着这基本上是一条死胡同呢？
I mean, what happened to these cities? If they were completely abandoned, were they forgotten about? I don't think they were. Yes, they were probably forgotten about? I don't think they were. Yes, they were probably forgotten about. And if we excavated a lot more, I'm sure we'd find more evidence and more sites. Nobody really knows what happened to them. And, you know, but what they've left behind
我的意思是，这些城市发生了什么？如果它们被彻底遗弃了，它们是被遗忘了吗？我认为没有。是的，它们可能被遗忘了？我不认为它们被遗忘了。是的，它们可能被遗忘了。如果我们进行更多的发掘，我确信我们会找到更多的证据和更多的遗址。没有人真正知道它们发生了什么。而且，你知道的，它们留下的
are more mysteries and questions than they have left answers. Fabulous. Okay, well, that's a great one. That's a very interesting one. So that's sort of that's a great very interesting one so that's so that's sort of at that point would you say that indus sort of valley civilization is it's one of a handful on the world isn't it i mean this must have been one of the most glittering cities on earth at the time absolutely it had lots of people living there it had people who were traveling and
谜团和问题，比它们留下的答案还要多。太棒了。好吧，这是一个极好的例子。这是一个非常有趣的例子。所以，在那个时候，你会说印度河流域文明是世界上屈指可数的文明之一吗？我的意思是，这在当时一定地球上最灿烂的城市之一。绝对的，那里生活着大量的人口，有到处旅行的人，
trade happening so this would have been this would have been a high point of urban life. And I really hope that we can sort of go. And there are more archaeological discoveries that are happening. There are people who are analyzing data. We're looking at objects more carefully. But the fact is that we don't really know very much, but we are finding more every day. OK. We're moving quite slowly, Tom, already, I noticed. But the fact is that we don't really know very much, but we are finding more every day. Okay. We're moving quite slowly, Tom, already, I noticed. Oh, God, are we? We're in a Rachel Morley situation.
还有贸易活动发生，所以这可以说是城市生活的一个巅峰。我真的希望我们能继续探索。而且还有更多的考古发现正在发生。有人在分析数据。我们正在更仔细地研究文物。但事实是，我们其实了解得并不多，但我们每天都在发现更多。好吧。汤姆，我注意到我们的进度已经相当慢了。但事实是，我们其实了解得并不多，但我们每天都在发现更多。好吧。汤姆，我注意到我们的进度已经相当慢了。哦，天哪，是吗？我们陷入蕾切尔·莫雷那种境地了。
We're not going to be in one. Okay, that's good. Those are brave words. Yes, because I have notes, and I have decided to stick to my notes. Okay. Number two, then. Number two. My second site is a site that i don't know if
我们不会陷入那种境地的。好吧，那就好。这话听着挺有底气的。是的，因为我有笔记，而且我决定按笔记来。那么，第二座。第二座。我的第二个遗址是一个我不知道
many people have heard about it's they're called the barabar caves tom do you know where they are uh i know i know intimately no very well yeah no so neither of us have heard of it so you um what you've heard of are rock cut temples right you've heard of are rock-cut temples, right? You've heard of cave sites across India. And these are probably some of the oldest cave sites there are. And they go back to the 3rd century before the common era. And they're basically a link to how architecture grows across the subcontinent. They belong to the Mauryan age. And they have Ashokan rock cut edicts and they're in a part of east of India called Bihar
有多少人听说过的遗址，它们被称为巴拉巴尔石窟（Barabar caves）。汤姆，你知道它们在哪儿吗？呃，我……我非常了解，不，非常清楚，是的，不，所以我们俩都没听说过。所以你……你听说过的是石窟寺，对吧？你听说过横跨印度的石窟遗址，对吧？这些可能是现存最古老的石窟遗址之一。它们可以追溯到公元前3世纪。它们基本上是了解整个次大陆建筑如何发展的一个纽带。它们属于孔雀王朝（Mauryan age）时期。那里有阿育王（Ashoka）的摩崖敕令，它们位于印度东部一个叫做比哈尔邦（Bihar）的地方。
so these are third century caves and you can see how architecture develops from wood and bamboo to carving in stone so there's a mimicking of various material that you can see you talked about this being the Mauryan empire can you say something about that for those of us of little brain who don't know what that is?
所以这些是公元前3世纪的石窟，你可以从中看到建筑是如何从木材和竹子发展到在石头上雕刻的，所以你能看到对各种材料的模仿。你提到这是孔雀帝国，能为我们这些不太懂、不知道那是什么的人稍微解释一下吗？
Yes, of course. So the Mauryans is a very large empire that takes over a huge chunk of the country. And the most famous Mauryan king was Ashoka. And he converts to Buddhism at one point and it's basically... Because he's so upset by the battle, isn't he? That's the story. That's what they say. I mean, you know, why do emperors... It makes for a neat story. Do you want to quickly tell us the story, you know, Tom?
好的，没问题。孔雀帝国是一个非常庞大的帝国，它占据了该国的大片领土。最著名的孔雀王朝国王是阿育王。他后来皈依了佛教，这基本上是因为……因为他对战争感到无比痛心，不是吗？故事是这样的。他们是这么说的。我的意思是，你知道的，为什么皇帝们……这构成了一个精彩的故事。汤姆，你想不想快点把这个故事讲给我们听？
No, no, well... It's not Tom's podcast. Tom, get off the podcast. So, I mean, it is a very romantic story that he's this great conqueror and he wins a great battle and he's so upset by the battle that he becomes a Buddhist. But what I've always thought the point of the story was that he only decides to become a Buddhist after he's won the battle. So he's already got the empire. Yes. He's virtue signalling. Is that what he's doing? Well, possibly. That might be one way to put it. So, interestingly, the tales that we get to know about the Mauryans also come from Greek sources, right?
不，不，好吧……这不是汤姆的播客。汤姆，别主持播客了。所以，我的意思是，这是一个非常浪漫的故事，说他是一位伟大的征服者，赢得了一场大战，然后对这场战争感到如此心碎，以至于他皈依了佛教。但我一直认为这个故事的重点在于，他是在打赢了战争之后才决定皈依佛教的。所以他当时已经拥有了帝国。是的。他在进行道德标榜（virtue signalling）。他是在这么做吗？嗯，有可能。这可能是其中一种说法。所以，有趣的是，我们了解到的关于孔雀王朝的传说也来自于希腊的史料，对吧？
So you have Greek diplomats who are in Pataliputra, which is now Patna in the east of India. And then you've got several people who are traveling in. And Ashoka is a later king who also sort of expands it and leaves a lot of, he leaves stone and rock cut edicts. Now, I should probably tell you that Ashoka was reading around 273 to 232 before Common Era and is one of the greatest sort of, you know, legendary kings of India. But, and also just, I mean, just, you know, you talked about the Greek influences. So this is in the wake of Alexander the Great kind of crashing into the Indus. And so this is a period where you have Greek-Indian influences kind of mixing
所以你会发现有希腊外交官身处华氏城（Pataliputra）——也就是现在印度东部的巴特那（Patna）。然后你还会发现有几个人在那里旅行。阿育王是后来的国王，他也扩大了版图，留下了大量的石刻和摩崖敕令。现在，我可能应该告诉你，阿育王在位时间大约是公元前273年至公元前232年，是印度最伟大的传奇国王之一。但是，同时，我的意思是，你知道的，你刚才提到了希腊的影响。所以这是在亚历山大大帝（Alexander the Great）横扫印度河之后的余波中发生的。因此这是一个希腊与印度的影响力相互交融、混合的时期。
and mingling with each other. Not only will Greek influences mix and mingle, but they'll also leave a legacy of art and architecture. And Buddhism will bring beautiful rock, beautiful sculptures that will have Hellenistic influences. But this is happening not only in the northwest frontier province, which is mostly Afghanistan and that sort of region, but you see it across the north of India.
不仅希腊的影响会相互交融，它们还将留下艺术和建筑的遗产。佛教将带来精美的岩石雕塑，这些雕塑将带有希腊化（Hellenistic）的影响。但这种情况不仅发生在西北边境省——那里主要是阿富汗和那个地区，你在整个印度北部都能看到这种现象。
So this is a period. I think the one thing to realise is that you never have watertight, sort of independent civilisations that don't have connections to the world. Everything is a clash of civilisations. Everything is an encounter of different people. And that's what you see reflected in art and architecture. Yeah. So, Panna, we did an episode on Afghanistan and we talked about the way in which the wealth of India is constantly attracting outsiders, mostly coming through the Hindu Kush and so on. So Alexander would be, I guess, an example of that. So number three, what's number three?
所以这是一个时期。我认为有一点需要认识到，那就是你永远不会有那种与世隔绝、互不相干、与世界毫无联系的独立文明。一切都是文明的冲突。一切都是不同人群的相遇。而这正是你在艺术和建筑中看到的反映。是的。那么，阿帕娜，我们曾做过一期关于阿富汗的节目，我们讨论了印度财富如何不断吸引外来者的方式，他们大多通过兴都库什山脉（Hindu Kush）等等进入。所以亚历山大我想就是其中的一个例子。那么第三个是什么？第三个是什么？
Number three is a site called Udaigiri, which literally means that it is the hill of the rising sun, as it were, in Madhya Pradesh, that's the central province in India, and a small town called Vidisha. Now, everyone thinks about this part of the world and thinks about the great Sanchi Stupa, which is where they thought the relics of Buddha would be. But that's not the site we're going to talk about.
第三个是一个叫做乌代吉里（Udaigiri）的遗址，字面意思是“旭日之山”，它位于中央邦（Madhya Pradesh）——那是印度的中部省份，在一个叫维迪沙（Vidisha）的小镇上。现在，每个人一想到世界这一部分，就会想到伟大的桑吉大塔（Sanchi Stupa），人们认为那里供奉着佛陀的舍利。但那不是我们要谈论的遗址。
We're talking about Udaigiri and specifically cave number five in Udaigiri. Another cave. You love a cave. I do love a good cave. It's all caves with you. It is all caves with me. So cave number five is not how you typically imagine a cave, which is a dark space that you have to sort of crawl into. When you walk up Vidishat, when you walk up Udaigiri, where we are, you basically find yourself in an audience sort of hall structure, where there's a massive stone carved Varaha, which is the Bor Avtar of the great god Vishnu.
我们要谈论的是乌代吉里，具体来说是乌代吉里的第5号洞窟。又是一个洞窟。你可真喜欢洞窟。我确实喜欢好洞窟。你走哪儿都离不开洞窟。我确实离不开洞窟。所以第5号洞窟并不是你通常想象的那种需要你爬进去的黑暗空间。当你走到维迪沙，当你走到我们所在的乌代吉里时，你会发现自己置身于一个类似于大厅结构的场所，那里有一尊巨大的石雕野猪（Varaha），它是伟大神明毗湿奴（Vishnu）的野猪化身（Boar Avtar）。
And he's rescuing Bhudevi, who signifies the earth goddess. And in audience is Chandragupta II, who is a Gupta king. And this is a very, very important site because it also makes a clear link between divinity and kingship and you've got um and while there is the earth is being rescued perhaps the protector of earth in this realm chandragupta is in audience so it's a very important and quite a spectacular cave site and um and that's my choice number three so chandra gupta he is the guy is he the guy that gives a load of elephants to the uh to salukas the one of alexander's successors is that one of his claims to fame okay everyone gives elephants to everyone oh okay all right i'm sorry
他正在拯救大地女神布陀毗（Bhudevi）。在场旁听的是笈多王朝（Gupta）的国王旃陀罗笈多二世（Chandragupta II）。这是一个非常非常重要的遗址，因为它也在神性与王权之间建立了清晰的联系，你拥有……而且正当大地被拯救时，此世的大地保护者旃陀罗笈多正在一旁观礼，所以这是一个非常重要且相当壮观的石窟遗址，嗯，这就是我的第三个选择。所以旃陀罗笈多，他就是那个……他是不是那个给亚历山大的继承人之一——塞琉古（Seleucus）送了一大堆大象的人？那是他的名声来源之一吗？好吧，每个人都送大象给别人。哦，好吧，好吧。对不起。
is that just that's just a constant theme of indian history the transfer of elephants if you if you came if you came to India, I'd get you an elephant too. Oh, that's such a lovely invitation. Thank you. So Chandrakumar, of course, Chandrakumar II is, of course, a very important king. And this kind of articulation of kingship and power hasn't quite really been seen before. We're looking at this massive site. It also has several other sculptures.
难道这只是印度历史上的一个恒定主题吗？大象的转让？如果你来到印度，我也会给你弄一头大象的。哦，这真是个可爱的邀请。谢谢你。所以旃陀罗笈多，当然了，旃陀罗笈多二世当然是一位非常重要的国王。这种对王权和权力的表达方式以前从未真正见过。我们正在看这个宏大的遗址。它还有几座其他的雕塑。
But when I say it's massive, it is taller than Thomas, right? So it is larger than life. And you have to look this site up because while we're in presence of divinity and kingship, you've got several other gods, including the gods of the snake land, so Nagadevdas, who are all in attendance as this boar god rescues Bhudevi. So even the choice of having a person, having the king depicted in presence of this sort of of this tableau is quite significant and we're now in the fifth century so because because upon one of the the things that immediately strikes someone going
但当我说是宏大时，它是比汤姆还要高的，对吧？所以它超乎寻常。你必须去查查这个遗址，因为在我们处于神圣与王权的存在之中的同时，你还有其他几位神明，包括蛇界之神（Nagadevdas），当野猪神拯救布陀毗时，他们都在一旁侍奉。因此，甚至选择让一个人、让国王被描绘在这种群雕呈现的存在之中，也是相当意义重大的。我们现在正处于公元5世纪，因为——因为阿帕娜，欧洲人来到印度时，有一个事情会立刻震撼到他们——所以在欧洲，所有的古典神明都已经消失了，再也没有人崇拜他们了；而在印度，你刚才谈到了毗湿奴，毗湿奴依然受到崇拜。所以这种建造寺庙的传统一直是一项活生生的传统。而且那种历史依然鲜活的感觉——或许在印度，历史不像在欧洲那样仅仅属于遥远的过去——总是让我感到非常震撼，我一直这么觉得。嗯，我也认为崇拜的形式会发生变化，你知道的，宗教会变得流行，然后消亡。所以在很长一段时间里，佛教曾在建造这些宏大遗址中如此重要，甚至有国王转信佛教，但它后来却从次大陆上消失了。同样地，
from Europe to India so in Europe all the kind of the classical gods are gone nobody worships them anymore in India the you know you talked about Vishnu. Vishnu is still worshipped. So this tradition of temple building remains a living one. And the sense of, you know, that history is alive, perhaps in India in a way that the distant past isn't in Europe is really striking, I always found. Well, I also think that forms of worship change and, you know, religions become fashionable and then they go away. So for a long time, Buddhism, which was so important in building these massive sites with kings turning Buddhists, it just disappeared from the subcontinent. In the same way,
偶像破坏（iconoclasm）不断降临到这些伟大的遗址上，某种特定宗教的兴起，然后它消退了，有时它又被找回，或者一个神话般的过去被不断找回，以使统治合法化，这种现象是存在的，但它并不是以人们实践宗教的同一种方式进行的……所以，虽然寺庙一直在建造，但它们在不断变化。有更新的神话产生。有更新的遗址被建造。
iconoclasm constantly happens to these great sites where you have the rise of a certain kind of religion and then it fades away and then sometimes it's retrieved or or a mythical past gets retrieved constantly to to legitimize rule um is there but it's not in the same way um that religion is practiced so while while temples are being built um they constantly change. And there are newer myths that happen. There are newer sites that get built.
即使在视觉上，事物也是不同的。这太棒了，因为它使你能够选择那些例证了印度历史特定时期的建筑，否则整个项目就无法进行下去了。所以第三个，我们必须说，第四个是什么？第四个。我们谈论宗教这一点非常有趣，因为我们现在要转换方向，从耆那教-佛教遗址转向一个穆斯林遗址。
Even visually, things are different. And that's brilliant because it enables you to choose buildings that exemplify certain periods of Indian history. And otherwise, this whole project wouldn't be working. So number three, we've got to say, what's number four? Number four. And it's very interesting that we are talking about, you know, religions, because we're now going to change track from, you know, from a Jain Buddhist site to a Muslim site.
我们现在来到了公元7世纪，来到了喀拉拉邦（Kerala）的切拉曼贾玛清真寺（Cheraman Jama Masjid）。所以喀拉拉邦位于……公元7世纪，来到了喀拉拉邦的切拉曼贾玛清真寺。所以喀拉拉邦在印度南部？喀拉拉邦在印度南部，在马哈拉施特拉邦和孟买以南。那是罗马船只曾经去过的地方。那是圣托马斯（St. Thomas）据说去过的地方，对吧？那是……是的。
And we're now in the 7th century and in the land of Kerala, to the Cheraman Jama Masjid. So Kerala is in the southth century and in the land of Kerala to the Cheraman Jama Masjid. So Kerala is in the south of India? Kerala is in the south of India, further down from Maharashtra and Bombay. And it's the land where Roman ships would go. It's where supposedly St. Thomas went, isn't it? It is where, yes.
所以它是向中东开放的？它是向……是的。所以它是向中东开放的。它是向中东开放的，也是向阿拉伯人开放的。那里的第一座清真寺建成了。这座清真寺是在先知在世时建造的，当时切拉曼国王（Chairman King）皈依了伊斯兰教，因为他做了一个梦，梦见月亮裂成了两半。这与先知在麦加为人们——为那些不相信他的人——施展的奇迹是同一种。他感到很困惑。国王对这个梦的含义感到十分困惑。一个阿拉伯人向他解释了。所以关于伊斯兰教是如何传入喀拉拉邦的，
So it's open to the Middle East? It is open to It is. So it's open to the Middle East. It is open to the Middle East and it's open to the Arabs. And that's where you have the first mosque being built. And this mosque was built in the lifetime of the prophet, where the chairman king converts to Islam because he has a dream where the moon splits into two. And it's the same sort of miracle that that the prophet has performed in Mecca for for people, those for people who don't believe him. And he's quite puzzled. The king is quite puzzled about what this this dream means. And an Arab tells him. So there are lots of legends around how Islam got to Kerala
以及切拉曼·佩鲁马尔统治者（Chairman Perumal Ruler）为什么最终皈依，有许多传说。但有趣的是，第一座清真寺的遗址至今犹存。因此，在大约1505年，葡萄牙人入侵并摧毁了这座清真寺——贾玛清真寺。有趣的是，这里仍然保留着一座最初建筑外观的模型，展示了原貌。我们拥有了通往6世纪清真寺、通往印度7世纪清真寺的直接连结与参考。这太惊人了。我能问个问题吗，阿帕娜？是的，请讲。你认为他为什么会皈依？
and why the chairman Perumal Ruler basically converted. But what's interesting is that the site of the first mosque still stands. So in about 1505, the Portuguese come in and destroy this mosque, the Jama Masjid. And what is interesting is that there's still a model of what the original looked like and what the original was like. And we have a direct link and references to what a sixth century mosque, what a seventh century mosque in India would be. That's amazing. Can I ask a question, Aparna? Yes, please. Why do you think he converted?
因为通常皈依与政治、与某种外交手段是密不可分的。例如，人们会采纳基督教，正统基督教，因为他们想要巴结君士坦丁堡或者其他什么势力。但如果这发生在先知在世的时期，印度人皈依伊斯兰教能得到什么好处呢？所以我们来看看喀拉拉邦，它也有着非常不同的社会经济结构。
Because often conversion goes hand in hand with kind of politics, with kind of diplomacy. So people would adopt Christianity, for example, because they, you know, Orthodox Christianity, because they wanted to curry favour with Constantinople or something. But if this is in the lifetime of the prophet, what is in it for the Indians in converting to Islam? So we're looking at Kerala, which also has a very different socio-economic structure.
它与该国其他地区并不相同。马拉巴尔海岸（Malabar coast），尤其是这个地区，有着多种联系。所以这种从……转向伊斯兰教的运动，或者向伊斯兰教的靠拢，很可能有利于——会撼动原有的宫廷惯例。我假设统治者皈依伊斯兰教背后，一定也有着强有力的社会经济和政治原因。阿帕娜，你是不是也说过，我的意思是，基督徒到达了那里，那里还有一座犹太会堂。所以你既有犹太人、基督徒，而伊斯兰教又是那种……某种程度上汲取了犹太教和基督教传统的宗教。所以也许它已经为此做好了铺垫。而且我想象中，喀拉拉邦的这座清真寺——它大概是由商人和跨海而来的民众带来的——与后来印度的……
It isn't the same as the rest of the country is. The Malabar coast, especially this region, has several connections. So it's likely that this sort of movement from or the moving to Islam would be good for, would shake up pre-existing court practices. I'm assuming that there's also a strong socio-economic political reason why a ruler would convert. Apal, do you also say, I mean, so there's Christians get there and there's a synagogue. So you've got Jews and Christians and Islam is a kind of, you know, part of it draws on Jewish and Christian traditions. So perhaps it had kind of warmed things up. And I suppose the contrast between this mosque in Kerala, which is presumably brought by traders and by people crossing the sea, with the subsequent arrival of India,
入侵印度的穆斯林穿过现在的巴基斯坦进入北部，他们进入了北部，而喀拉拉邦则更靠南。是的，所以这是有区别的，不是吗？这是一个绝对的区别，但我们也必须记住，这里存在着跨海贸易的路线。因此海上航线是存在的。虽然，你知道的，一波又一波的入侵从北方涌入，但你通过阿拉伯海保持着持续的贸易关系。所以你与非洲有联系，你与阿拉伯世界有联系。这里一直是一个繁荣、充满活力的空间。现在，我必须还要说的是，如果你看看最初那座清真寺的模型，它极具喀拉拉邦的本土特色。
the Muslims who invade India are coming across what is now Pakistan into the north. They're coming into the north and Kerala is further down south. Yeah, so that's a difference, isn't it? It's an absolute difference, but we have to also remember that there are trade links over the sea. So sea routes exist. And while, you know, while waves of invasion come in from the north, you have sustained trade relationships that happen over the Arabian Sea. So you've got connections to Africa, you've got connections to the Arab world. And it's always been a thriving, vibrant space. Now, I have to also say that if you look at the model of what the original mosque was, it is extremely local to Kerala.
所以它不是圆顶结构。它看起来一点也不像《一千零一夜》里的奇幻建筑。它看起来就像你在喀拉拉邦能找到的建筑。而且据说它的朝向是反的。我不知道这个。我曾在网上读到一些东西，发现直到公元1000年，他们才设法……意识到，“哎呀，我们需要面向西方，而不是东方。”他们不得不调整祈祷的方向。伊斯兰教传入印度，显然是印度历史进程中一个绝对根本性的转折点。所以我们有……我不确定我是否同意这一点。哦，好吧。好吧。是的。因为我认为迄今为止的每一次相遇都是重要的，每一次相遇、每一次文化相遇——
So it's not a dome structure. It doesn't look like anything from an Arabian Nights fantasy. It looks like a building that you'd find in Kerala. And apparently it faced the wrong way. I don't know this. I was reading something online where I found that it was only in the year 1000 CE that they managed to, that they realised, oops, we need to face west, not east. And they had to change the mirror up. So the coming of Islam to India is obviously an absolutely fundamental kind of breakpoint
你知道的，无论是佛教的兴起、梵语时代的到来、吠代时代、希腊人进入这个国家，还是与中国的关系，我认为每一次这种相遇都是独立且令人印象深刻的。我想，就建筑而言，伊斯兰教认为只有一个神，而且它总体上
in the course of Indian history. So we have... I'm not sure I agree with that. Oh, okay. Okay. Yes. Because I think that every encounter so far is important every encounter every cultural encounter um you know whether it was the rise of Buddhism whether it was the the Sanskrit age whether the Vedic age um the you know the the um the Greeks coming into the country and and and and a relationship with China as well I think each each sort of encounter was independent and impressive. I suppose in terms of buildings, that Islam, there is only one God, and that it generally
不鼓励对人类形象的描绘，或许不像以往的传统那样。难道你不知道事实并非完全如此吗？好吧，我在用非常宽泛的粗线条在讲。汤姆，你在自己的播客里被上了一课。我知道。我这里讨论的确实是非常宽泛的宏观概念。但是，我的确——它确实引入了一种相当激进的全新艺术和建筑传统，你不觉得吗？而且图标主义（iconism），即不以人类形象进行描绘，这也是一种佛教实践。
doesn't encourage the portrayal of the human form, perhaps in the way that previous intraditions have done. Don't you also know that that is not quite true? Well, I'm dealing in very broad brush. Tom, you're being schooled in your own podcast. I know. I'm dealing in very broad brush terms here. But there is, I mean, it does kind of introduce quite a radically new artistic and architectural tradition, don't you think? And iconism, not depicting in human form, was also a Buddhist practice.
你曾看到佛陀被描绘成一棵树，即菩提树，被描绘成法轮，或者仅仅通过他的双足来表现。所以我认为次大陆对于表达神明、神性或重要人物的创造性方式一直相当习惯。伊斯兰教带来的是——它是一波一波带来的，对吧？而且在国家的各个地区，它看起来也不尽相同。
You had the Buddha depicted as a tree, as the Bodhi tree, as the wheel, as, you know, just by his feet. So I think the subcontinent was always quite used to creative ways of expressing God or divinity or important figures. What Islam brings, and it does so in waves, right? And in various parts of the country, it again looks different.
在喀拉拉邦，它看起来不同。如果我们开始思考伊斯兰教对德干（Deccan）的影响——这带来了一种独特的建筑传统，如果我们现在就去想这个，那就有点操之过急了，或者说至少超前了一站。中印度。中印度，从东海岸到西海岸，夹在两大山脉之间。所以你会发现，伊斯兰教很重要，但我们也认为我们有几个伟大的王国，其中两个我们将作为第5点来进行讨论。
In Kerala, it looks different. We're going ahead of ourselves, or at least one stop ahead of ourselves, if we start to think about the impact of Islam on the Deccan, which brings with it an architectural tradition of it. Central India. Central India, from east coast to west coast, and sort of sandwiched between two major mountain ranges. So you've got, Islam is important, but we also think we have several great kingdoms, and two of them we shall discuss now as point number five.
好吧，其实我们在中场休息后再讨论吧。我们在中场休息后再讨论。我们已经讲了四个，还有六个要讲。所以你已经超越了蕾切尔·莫雷和她的教堂了。我当时讲到第三个。所以我们现在休息一下。汤姆，别总打断我的议程。对不起。我知道。我真的很抱歉。下半场我不会了。这太糟糕了。
Well, actually, let's discuss after the break. Let's discuss after the break. So we've done four and we've got six to go. So you've worn up on Rachel Morley with the churches. I've done three by this point. So we will take a break now. Tom, don't constantly distract me from my agenda. I'm sorry. I know. I'm really sorry. And I won't in the second half. It's bad. it is bad. We will be back in a minute.
这确实很糟糕。我们一会儿回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦，
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip
而在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。这里发生了戏剧性的一幕，汤姆·霍兰德发誓——他在中场休息时公开并私下发誓，他在下半场将闭嘴不言，让阿帕娜带我们领略她剩余的六座将解释全部印度历史的建筑。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Extraordinary scenes here, as Tom Holland has pledged. He has pledged publicly and he pledged privately during the break that he would stop talking in the second half and allow Aparna to take us through her remaining six buildings that will explain all of Indian history.
非常令人兴奋的时刻。那么，阿帕娜，你现在讲到第……我们讲到第几个了？现在是第五个。第五个。我们讲到第五个了。我必须说，汤姆和我为此进行了一场电子邮件大战，因为我们现在已经进入了人们可能认为是中世纪印度的时期。我们具体向南移动。
Very exciting moment. So, Aparna, you're on to number... What are we on? Number five now. Number five. We're on number five. And I have to say that Tom and I had a bit of an email war over this because we've now moved into what people might think of as medieval India. And we're moving specifically south.
我们谈到了喀拉拉邦。我们稍微深入到内陆了一点。我们在思考南方的超级大国，朱罗王朝（Chola）和毗奢耶那伽罗王国（Vijayanagara）。现在，这些王国中的每一个都可以也应该拥有它们自己的播客，而且这方面有专家，所以我只打算谈谈位于坦贾武尔（Thanjavur）的罗阇罗阇ेश्वर拉贾雷杰什瓦拉神庙（Raja Rajeshwara temple），那是朱罗王朝建造的。这是一座宏大的寺庙，它将彻底改变印度此后的寺庙建造方式。那么，阿帕娜，这座寺庙是什么时候建造的？所以罗阇罗阇·朱罗（Raja Rajeshwara Chola）在公元1003年至1010年间建造了布里哈迪希瓦拉神庙（Vrideshwara temple）。
We've spoken about Kerala. We're going into the mainland a little bit. And we're thinking about southern superpowers, the kingdoms of Chola and the Vijayanagara kingdoms. Now, each of these kingdoms could and should have their own podcasts and there are experts in this so i am going to only talk about the raja rajeshwara temple um in thanjavur that the cholas built this is a massive temple it's come it is going to completely change the way temple building will happen in India after this. And so, Pranay, when is this temple built? So Raja Rajeshwara Chola builds the Vrideshwara temple between 1000 and 3 to 1010 CE.
所以我们现在处于公元第二个千年了。它位于印度南部的坦贾武尔。而且它非常宏大。你现在看到的是，有几种建筑风格融入其中。所以你拥有维玛纳（Vimana，主殿塔楼），你拥有曼达帕（Mandapa，大殿），你拥有一种独立于北方寺庙建筑风格——被称为纳加拉风格（Nagara）——的独特建筑风格。在这里，我们拥有的是达罗毗荼风格（Dravidar）的建筑。
So we're in the millennium now. And it's in Tanjavur, which is in southern India. And it's massive. And what you have is that there are several architectural styles that now come in. So you have the Vimana, you have the Mandapa, you have a different style of architecture that's separate from the northern styles of temple architecture, which is called the Nagara. And here we have the Dravidar style of architecture.
这座建筑的尖顶（Spire）高约216英尺。因此，室哈罗（Shikara）直冲云霄，与之相比，其他一切都相形见绌。所以这是一个工程学的宣言。这是朱罗王朝建造的一座超越现实的宏伟寺庙。在建造宏伟建筑的同时，他们还制作了你在世界各地收藏中都能看到的这些精美绝伦的青铜雕塑。它们绝对是妙不可言的。所以这两点都有。而且他们是印度教国王。
The spire, as it were, of this is about 216 feet high. So the Shikara goes right up and everything else is dwarfed against this. So it is a statement of engineering. It's a larger than life temple building that the Cholas have built. And while they build large, they also make these gorgeous bronze sculptures that you see in collections around the world. And they're absolutely sublime. So these are the two. And they're Hindu kings.
如果他们建造规模如此宏大的建筑，那他们一定极其富有。这样说公平吗？他们确实非常非常富有。绝对的。他们以此确立了自己作为最富有的王朝、作为某个非常有影响力的存在。这就是朱罗建筑的巅峰之作，布里哈迪希瓦拉神庙。
If they're building big, then they must be incredibly rich. Is that fair to say? They are very, very rich. Absolutely. And this is what they're sort of establishing themselves as the richest dynasty, as someone very, very influential. And this is just the high point of Chola architecture, the Bredeshwara temple.
阿帕娜，我可以插话吗？你刚才说这是中世纪。我们正在进入中世纪的印度。但中世纪是一个欧洲的概念，对吧？我的意思是，真的有“中世纪的印度”这种说法吗？这有任何意义吗？不，没有。因为印度的中世纪是不同的。
And Aparna, can I jump in? You said this was medieval. We're getting into medieval India. But medieval is a kind of European concept, right? I mean, is there such a thing as medieval India? Does that make any sense? No, it doesn't. Because medieval India is different.
但我认为我对中世纪的理解基本上是——我是用欧洲的术语来思考的，即把它夹在7世纪到大约14世纪之间，对吧？所以，你知道的，从伊斯兰教的诞生到文艺复兴，如果你是这样理解中世纪的话。所以我不喜欢“中世纪”这个词，尽管我在爱丁堡开始攻读的学位就被称为“全球中世纪的艺术”，我们当时花时间去剖析这个词，讨论什么是中世纪。我下周还要上一堂关于印度中世纪的课，我们当时……而这几乎已经是近代早期了，你知道的，我接下来要进入的时期。
But I think how I would think of medieval is basically, I was thinking about this in European terms, where you're sort of bookending it between the 7th century to about the 14th, right? So, you know, birth of Islam to Renaissance, if that's how you understand medieval. So I don't like the term medieval although my degree was called um that i started in edinburgh was called art in the global middle ages and we spent time just sort of pulling that apart saying what is the middle age um i'm also teaching a class next week on medieval india and we're and that's almost early modern um you know, the period I'm going into.
所以，不，不，不赞成“中世纪”这个说法。但稍晚一些时候，也就是在公元1000年至1400年之间，发生了一件事，一个首都、一个伟大的王国正在被巩固。这就是毗奢耶那伽罗王国（Vijayanagara kingdom），其首都亨比（Hampi）大约建立于1343年。亨比目前处于荒郊野岭。你无法直飞亨比。要么需要坐很长时间的火车、长途汽车，要么得开车行驶好几个小时。它之所以会在那个地方，是因为它也建立在一个具有文化意义和先前宗教意义的古代遗址之上。所以亨比被称为——亨比周边地区曾被称为基什金达（Kishkindha），这与《罗摩衍那》（Ramayana）有关。但在这里，你拥有宏大的寺庙，有建造的宫殿，你拥有这些巨大的、你知道的，石头结构和战车形状的结构，以及寺庙战车形状的结构，我是指这些。阿帕娜，你提到它是因为我说我想要它，基本上。你想要它，是的。
So no, no, no to medieval. But what happens a little bit later, also between 1000 to 1400 CE, is that a capital, a great kingdom is being consolidated. And that is the Vijayanagara kingdom and its capital, Hampi, is founded in about 1343. Hampi is currently in the middle of nowhere. You can't take a direct flight to Hampi. It's either a long train ride, bus ride, or you drive down for hours. And the reason why it is where it is, is because it also stands on an ancient site that has cultural significance and previous religious significance. So Hampi is called, and the regions around Hampi were called Kishkindha, which has a Ramayana reference. But here you have massive temples, you have palaces that are built, you've got these huge, you know, stone structures and chariot sort of structures and temple chariot structures, I mean. And, Apana, you've mentioned it because I said I wanted it, basically. You wanted it, yes.
我对此表现得非常霸道。汤姆，这太令人震惊了。我知道是的。你邀请了别人来，然后把别人晾在一边，告诉别人该做什么。我礼貌地提出了建议。这很礼貌吗？好吧。这礼貌吗，阿帕娜？
I was very bullying about this. Tom, that's shocking. I know it is. You invite somebody on and then you toss them around and tell them what to do. I politely suggested. Was it polite? Which is fine. Was it polite, Afana?
非常礼貌。所以它成了5B版块的5B。这是一个如此神奇的地方。我看到它时，我大概只有18岁。从那以后我就再也没有回去过了。但我依然清晰地记得它是我去过的最非凡的地方之一。而且当我当时去那里时，它绝对是我去过最非凡的地方。
It was very polite. So it became 5B at 5B. It's such an amazing place. So I saw it. I must have been 18 when I saw it. And I haven't been back since. But I still remember it vividly as one of the most extraordinary places I've ever been. And certainly when I went there, it was the most extraordinary place I've ever been.
它是如此广袤。我想我记得有人说它是当时除中国之外世界上最大的城市。正如你所说，它位于荒郊野岭。这太惊人了。它拥有一条美丽绝伦的河流——通加巴德拉河（Tungabhadra）。所以，你知道，它坐落在一个盆地里，
And it is so enormous. And I think I seem to remember it was people saying that it was the largest city in the world outside China, perhaps at that time. And as you say, it's in the middle of nowhere. It's astonishing. And it has this gorgeous river, the Tungabhadra. So, you know, it's in a basin
它原本就是为了给人留下深刻印象而建的。在建造这座宏伟城市时，他们很清楚自己在做什么。毗奢耶那伽罗可能也是那个帝国，你知道的，它是庞大的，有着巨大的影响力。当毗奢耶那伽罗帝国走向崩溃时，它在该地区催生了新的势力。巴黑曼尼王朝（Bahamanids）接管了这里，你迎来了大型穆斯林帝国的进入，它与伊朗和中亚有着联系。从而带来了一种完全不同的视觉语言和建筑风格。那么，这座城市后来怎么样了？
and it was meant to impress. And they knew what they were doing with this sort of building of this grand city. And Vijayanagara is probably also the empire, you know, was was massive, had great influences. And when the Vijayanagara empire sort of collapsed, it gave rise in that space. The Bahamanids took over and you had the entry of the large Muslim empire that also had links to Iran and Central Asia. So brought about a completely different visual language and architectural style. And what happened to the city then?
而且它旨在留下深刻印象。他们建造这座宏伟城市时很清楚自己在做什么。维查耶纳伽罗可能也是一个庞大且极具影响力的帝国。当维查耶纳伽罗帝国崩溃时，它留下了真空。巴哈马尼王朝接管了这里，大型穆斯林帝国随之进入，该帝国还与伊朗和中亚有着联系。因此，这带来了完全不同的视觉语言和建筑风格。那么这座城市后来怎么样了？
If it's in the middle of nowhere, is it just going to decline or do people loot it or what happens so it goes into decline i think people i i think yes a bit of looting would happen because these are also when you have temples they're also repositories of great wealth right so you've got people um who move away and i think it just sort of gets forgotten at some point because you have different building projects, capital shift, people move to where there's trade and commerce, right? So the seat of power is where you will have more people come in and stay. And so when that falls, it's the whole of India then under Muslim rule? Are there any
如果它在荒郊野岭，它是会直接荒废，还是会被人掠夺，或者发生什么？所以它会走向荒废。我想人们……我想是的，多多少少会发生一些掠夺，因为这些地方，当你有寺庙时，它们也是巨大财富的储藏库，对吧？所以你会有人……搬走，而且我认为它在某种程度上就会被遗忘，因为你们会有不同的建筑项目、首都的转移、人们会搬到有贸易和商业的地方，对吧？所以权力中心才是会有更多人涌入并留下的地方。那么当那个地方陷落时，整个印度就都处在穆斯林统治之下了吗？还有任何
Hindu kingdoms left? But they're different. So there are different empires. The Bahamanids never quite take over. They don't go sort of the north of the Vindhyas. So they stick to the Deccan. But are there any independent Hindu kingdoms left? Yes, of course, there will be independent kingdoms and there will be kings who are fighting. Varangal would be one. So you do have them in pockets. And we're still, it's such a massive country, right? Such a, you know, so nobody really ever until, and not even, you know, not even English colonisation, takes over completely.
印度教王国残留吗？但它们是不同的。所以有不同的帝国。巴哈马尼王朝从未真正完全接管。它们没有向北越过温迪亚山脉。所以它们坚守在德干。但还有任何独立的印度教王国残留吗？是的，当然，会有独立的王国，也会有在战斗的国王。瓦朗加尔就是一个。所以你确实在一些角落里能找到它们。而且我们依然……这是一个如此巨大的国家，对吧？如此……你知道，所以直到……甚至，你知道，甚至连英国殖民统治，也从来没有人真正完全占领过。
Okay, so these great medieval Hindu kingdoms collapse. Yes, they collapse. With exceptions, India is now largely Muslim ruled. Yes. And we're going into the early modern period. So what do we have at number six? We're now travelling further north. So number six is perhaps one of the most beautiful sites and a very interesting and contested site, too. You've heard of this, you know, slightly tall building called the Qutub Minar, which basically is is a large.
好吧，所以这些伟大的中世纪印度教王国崩塌了。是的，它们崩塌了。除了个别例外，印度现在基本上由穆斯林统治。是的。我们要进入近代早期了。那么第六个是什么？我们现在正向更北方进发。所以第六个也许是最美丽的遗址之一，也是一个非常有趣且备受争议的遗址。你听说过这座，你知道的，稍微有点高的建筑，叫做顾特卜塔，它基本上是一个宏大的……
It's a tower of victory as it were and it's a 12th century complex called the Kutub Minar complex in the heart of Delhi now in the heart of Delhi but in one of the old cities of Delhi called Mehroli and it's a set of very interesting sites so 12th century complex built by the sultanates by the sultanate. And you've got a fourth or fifth century pillar. You've got the Qutub Minar itself, which was built around 1192. The pillar is made of iron, isn't it? The pillar is made of iron. And which is kind of very unusual at the time, a whole pillar of iron.
它可以说是胜利之塔，这是一个被称为顾特卜塔建筑群的12世纪建筑群，位于德里市中心，现在德里市中心，但在德里的一座古城内，名叫梅赫罗利，这是一组非常有趣的遗址——所以是由苏丹国、由苏丹王朝建造的12世纪建筑群。你有一个四世纪或五世纪的柱子。你有顾特卜塔本身，它大约建于1192年。这根柱子是铁做的，对吧？这根柱子是铁做的。而且这在当时相当罕见，整根柱子都是铁的。
No, not really, because you had several of these sort of monolithic or iron pillars, and they were experimenting, and they were putting them around the country. So Ashokan pillars were everywhere. Most of them were stone. I don't think that this was an exception in that sense. But to pick up on Tom's earlier point about the previous site, they must be incredibly rich to be building pillars, to have tons of iron to be building pillars to i mean have tons of iron to be building they're mining and i also suppose that um they would reuse a lot of this as time goes on right but they're definitely rich aren't they you mean we're a rich country yes poor people yes so so tell us more tell us more about the kutub Minar. So you've got, and the reason why I've
不，其实不然，因为你曾拥有好几根这种单块巨石或铁柱，而且他们一直在进行试验，并把它们放置在全国各地。所以阿育王的柱子到处都是。它们大多数是石头的。我不认为这根柱子在这层意义上是个例外。但顺着汤姆刚才关于前一个遗址的观点，他们一定极其富有，才能建造柱子，拥有成吨的铁来建造柱子，我的意思是，拥有成吨的铁来建造……他们在开采，而且我也假设……随着时间的推移，他们会重复利用很多这些东西，对吧？但他们绝对很富裕，不是吗？你是说我们是个富裕的国家？是的，穷人是的……所以，给我们讲讲，给我们讲讲更多关于顾特卜塔的事。所以你有……我之所以选择
picked the Qutub Minar is not because it's such a fantastic structure with, you know, beautiful calligraphic panels and the use of sandstone and all of that. Why I've picked this is because it's got a set of very interesting structures around it. So you've got the iron pillar, which is for the 5th century of the Qutub Minar itself. You've got the iron pillar, which is for the 5th century, you've got the Qutub Minar itself, you've got the tomb of Iltutmish and Sultan Iltutmish died in 1235. You have the Alaya Minar and Darwaza from 1311. So the Qutub Minar mosque that gets built uses spolia, right? So they... So stuff nicked from other temples and things. Stuff nicked from Jain temples, Hindu temples.
顾特卜塔，不是因为它是一个多么棒的结构，拥有美丽的书法面板、砂岩的运用以及所有这些。我选择这个的原因是因为它周围有一组非常有趣的结构。所以你有铁柱，它是5世纪的……顾特卜塔本身。你有铁柱，它是5世纪的，你有顾特卜塔本身，你有伊勒杜米什陵墓，苏丹伊勒杜米什死于1235年。你有1311年的阿拉伊·米纳尔和达瓦扎清真寺。所以建造的顾特卜塔清真寺使用了抢掠来的建筑构件，对吧？所以他们……从其他寺庙和其他地方顺手牵羊来的东西。从耆那教寺庙、印度教寺庙顺手牵羊来的东西。
Now, what's important about the way spolia is used is that it's a very deliberate articulation of power and authority over other religions too. So it's not as simple as saying, hey, I've got this column, I'm going to just use it. But it also, you know, when you invert these things, so spolia is not innocent, is what I'm saying. Yeah, absolutely. I think that the Qutub Minar complex becomes very important and interesting. as iconoclasts and as people who would ruin temple sites just to build their own, is sort of, these sites like these give the whole iconoclasm and iconoclasts idea visual and material proof. Because what has happened is that in the past, everyone is iconoclastic, right? Buddhist cave sites get usurped by Hindu cave sites,
现在，使用抢掠构件的方式之所以重要，是因为这也是对其他宗教的一种非常刻意的权力和权威的宣示。所以它并不像说“嘿，我有这根柱子，我就用它”那么简单。但它也，你知道的，当你颠倒这些东西时，也就是这些抢掠构件并非无辜的，这就是我想说的。是的，绝对如此。我认为顾特卜塔建筑群变得非常重要且有趣。作为破坏圣像者，以及那些为了建造自己的建筑而毁坏寺庙遗址的人，像这样的一些遗址给整个破坏圣像和破坏圣像者的理念提供了视觉和物质上的证据。因为发生的事情是，在过去，每个人都有破坏圣像的倾向，对吧？佛教石窟遗址被印度教石窟遗址篡夺，
but you don't leave as much visual evidence or that evidence is lost indeed over centuries. But with a lot of Islamic rulers, especially around the 12th century, you have proof that temples were being brought down to create mosques. And I think that the whole narrative of iconoclastic Islam is reiterated constantly because of these very highly visible architectural patterns. So, number seven, what have we got? Number seven is we're now sort of inching closer to the early modern and we have another very important dynasty and that are the Grand Mughals who would never call themselves the Mughals
但你没有留下那么多的视觉证据，或者这些证据在几个世纪中丢失了。但对于许多伊斯兰统治者来说，特别是在12世纪左右，你有证据表明寺庙被推倒来建造清真寺。而且我认为，由于这些高度可见的建筑模式，反圣像异教的整个叙事不断被重复。所以，第七个，我们有什么？第七个是，我们现在正一步步接近近代早期，我们有另一个非常重要的王朝，那就是伟大的莫卧儿王朝，他们当然永远不会称自己为莫卧儿人，
of course because they think of Mughals as Ankhut, they would think of themselves as Timurid princes but we know them all as the Mughals and Mughals come to India with the young Prince Babar who wants to conquer.
因为他们认为莫卧儿人是野蛮人，他们会认为自己是帖木儿王朝的王子，但我们都称他们为莫卧儿人，莫卧儿人带着想要征服印度的年轻王子巴布尔来到印度。
And he's sort of getting thrown out of Central Asia, has to fight for his own land, and decides to head east to India. And one of the first things he does when he captures Kabul in Afghanistan is that he sets up a garden. He creates his own garden. This is a Persian thing, isn't it? The walled garden. It's a Persian idea. Yeah. It's a Persian idea that he brings in. And then his successors also illustrate the fact that Babur is building a garden. Babur was quite garden crazy. I mean, he had a green thumb. He liked his gardens. He missed fruits of Central Asia and cried, which I find that quite endearing about him because he misses his gardens he missed fruits of central asia and cried which i i find that quite endearing about him because he misses his home and he's trying to create a new home for
他有点被赶出中亚，不得不为自己的土地而战，并决定向东前往印度。当他在阿富汗攻占喀布尔时，他做的第一件事就是建立一座花园。他创造了自己的花园。这是波斯人的习俗，对吧？带围墙的花园。这是一个波斯概念。是的。这是他引入的一个波斯概念。然后他的继承人们也说明了巴布尔在建造花园的事实。巴布尔对花园简直有点疯狂。我的意思是，他很有园艺天赋。他喜欢他的花园。他思念中亚的水果并哭了，我发现他这一点相当可爱，因为他思念他的花园，他思念中亚的水果并哭了，我发现他这一点相当可爱，因为他思念他的家园，并且正在试图为自己创造一个新的家园，
himself um whether you know other people liked or not um but i like the fact that one of the first things that you would build in the subcontinent and to make it your own is a garden so it's a romantic idea yeah so Yeah. So he founds the dynasty that in the long run the most famous monument is the Taj Mahal. Perhaps we should just very fleetingly... He's desperate to talk about the Taj Mahal. Well, just very fleetingly mention it because
不管……你知道，其他人是否喜欢……但我喜欢这样一个事实：在次大陆建造的第一批东西之一，为了让它成为你自己的，就是一座花园，所以这是一个浪漫的想法，对吧？所以……是的。所以他创立了这个王朝，从长远来看，它最著名的纪念碑是泰姬陵。也许我们应该非常短暂地……他迫不及待地想谈论泰姬陵了。好吧，只是非常短暂地提一下，因为
that's... Yes. Well, yes, he founds the Mughal dynasty that builds the Taj Mahal, which is quite a lovely sight, it is. It's not bad, is it? I mean, it's not bad. It's not bad at all, no. But to Mughal architecture, Mughal architecture. Yes, Mughal architecture is great.
那是……是的。好吧，是的，他创立了建造泰姬陵的莫卧儿王朝，这是一个相当可爱的遗址，确实如此。它不赖，不是吗？我的意思是，它不赖。一点也不赖，不。但是对于莫卧儿建筑，莫卧儿建筑。是的，莫卧儿建筑很棒。
But I'll tell you my reservations about the Taj and the way we see it now is that the English came in and flattened all these gardens and gave us lawns there. So that's what I was going to ask, was that I remember going and the guide saying it was much more beautiful before the British came. There you go. Because gardens themselves were designed, and I think that, and which brings us back to Bhagavad Gita and fidelity,
但我得告诉你我对泰姬陵以及我们现在看到它的方式的保留意见，那就是英国人进来铲平了所有这些花园，并在那里给我们铺上了草坪。这就是我要问的，我记得我去过那里，导游说在英国人来之前它要美丽得多。你看。因为花园本身是经过设计的，而且我认为，这就把我们带回了薄伽梵歌和保真度，
is that you could never have seen the Taj in its entirety. You always got glimpses of it. And while you walk through, there were trees that had flowers and fragrances and fruits. So it was a multi-sensorial experience. And it's very important to also realize that tombs and gardens are not just for commemoration, but they're also a way of keeping land under control. So when you create a large tomb garden, it also means that your family can hold on to the land like that.
那就是你永远无法完整地看到泰姬陵。你总是只能惊鸿一瞥。当你穿行其中时，有开花的树木、芬芳的花香和果实。所以这是一种多感官的体验。而且认识到陵墓和花园不仅仅是为了纪念，也是一种控制土地的方式，这一点也非常重要。因此，当你建造一个大型陵墓花园时，这也意味着你的家族能够这样守住这块土地。
You know, more than just, it's not only just the architecture. But I also think that the Taj Mahal, you know, across from the river, if you sort of moved up river a little bit, it was a tomb of Idmat Ad tomb of it was a tomb of that daughter builds um which is just fabulous and and you know the work uh it's it's beautiful all of it is yeah it's the inlay and the marble and the sandstone so yes it's quite it's quite romantic. I like the way that we have actually cleverly smuggled in the Taj Mahal.
你知道，不仅仅是建筑。但我也认为，泰姬陵，你知道的，穿过河流，如果你顺流而上一点点，那是伊特马德·乌德·道拉陵墓，那是女儿建造的陵墓……这简直太棒了，而且你知道，这些工艺……它很美，所有这一切都是，是的，它是镶嵌工艺、大理石和砂岩，所以是的，它相当……相当浪漫。我喜欢我们实际上巧妙地把泰姬陵夹带进来的方式。
That was shameless, Tom. So that was shameless. So on to eight now. We're closing in. We're on to eight. And it's a good thing that we've spoken about the Taj Mahal because guess whom did the land belong to? It belonged to the Amber Jaipur rulers.
那太厚颜无耻了，汤姆。所以那太厚颜无耻了。那么现在进入第八个。我们快接近了。我们进入第八个。我们谈论了泰姬陵真是太好了，因为猜猜这片土地属于谁？它属于安柏-斋浦尔的统治者。
So the site for the Taj Mahal was bought from the rulers of the house of Amber, which later becomes Jaipur rulers. So the site for the Taj Mahal was bought from the rulers of the House of Amber, which later becomes Jaipur. And I'm dragging us, kicking and screaming, into the 18th century, where in 1727, the grand city of Jaipur is being built.
所以泰姬陵的遗址是从安柏家族的统治者那里买来的，安柏家族后来成为了斋浦尔的统治者。所以泰姬陵的遗址是从安柏家族（后来成为斋浦尔）的统治者那里买来的。而我正连拉带拽、哭喊着把大家带入18世纪，当时在1727年，伟大的斋浦尔城正在建设中。
So we're in Rajasthan and Dominic will know this because Udaipur is also in Rajasthan and Udaipur is in Octopussy. It is. Go on, tell your story.ipur is in Octopussy. It is. Go on, tell your story. Tell your story. I know what you're doing.
所以我们在拉贾斯坦邦，多米尼克会知道这一点，因为乌代浦也在拉贾斯坦邦，而乌代浦出现在《八爪女》里。确实如此。来吧，讲讲你的故事。浦尔出现在《八爪女》里。确实如此。来吧，讲讲你的故事。讲讲你的故事。我知道你在干什么。
Didn't you bowl out the Maharaja? No, I'm not mentioning it. I'm not mentioning it. In fact, I bowled the crown prince of Udaipur out. Yeah. Middle stump. I'm not going to tell that story. I'm distracting from a partner who's telling us about...
你不是把大君三振出局了吗？不，我没提这事。我没提这事。事实上，我把乌代浦的王储三振出局了。是的。中柱出局。我不打算讲那个故事。我是在转移注意力，不让我那个正在讲述……的人分心。
Yes, but you do know that if you can beat them at polo,'s the story to tell okay i've never played polo tom tom you've never seen someone a horse i mean no that's a very different uh very very different story we're galloping we've got to be running out of time here we're talking about me on a horse so stop dominic stop misbehaving apana so what we've got what we've got is got is that in the early decades of the 18th century, you have the great Mughal Empire that begins to crumble because Aurangzeb is dead. In the Mughal court, you've got Rajput rulers at very high positions and everyone sort of knows that there is a lacuna in power.
是的，但你确实知道，如果你能在马球上击败他们，那就是要讲的故事。好吧，我从来没打过马球，汤姆，汤姆，你从来没见过有人骑马……我的意思是，不，那是一个非常不同……非常非常不同的故事。我们在策马奔腾，我们这里快没时间了。我们在谈论我骑马的事，所以停下来，多米尼克，别胡闹了，阿帕娜。所以我们得到的、我们拥有的是，在18世纪的头几十年里，伟大的莫卧儿帝国开始崩溃，因为奥朗则布去世了。在莫卧儿宫廷里，你拥有处于极高地位的拉其普特统治者，每个人都多少知道权力出现了真空。
And what Savaiya Jaisingh II, who's a very high ranking official, what he does is that he abates on the wrong person to take over after the death of Aurangzeb, but also realizes that this is his chance to move into a kingdom of his own and to move from being a high ranking courtier to being a Maharaja of his own. He founds Jaipur in 1727 and designs it he is also an astronomer a mathematician so which is why you've got an observatory and Jaipur as a city is the world city is very cleverly designed in grids and he invites people to live in Jaipur it's an architectural marvel it's it has this unified facade of sand of of terracotta and um and it's plastered so it
而作为一名高级官员的萨瓦伊·杰伊辛格二世，他所做的是，他在奥朗则布死后押错了接班人，但也意识到这是他进入属于自己的王国、从一个高级朝臣转变为独立大君的机会。他在1727年创立了斋浦尔并设计了它。他同时也是一位天文学家、数学家，这就是为什么你拥有一个天文台，而斋浦尔作为一座城市、这座世界之城，其网格设计非常巧妙，他邀请人们住在斋浦尔，这是一座建筑奇迹，它有着这种由砂岩、由红土组成的统一立面，而且被抹了灰，所以它……
you know which is why it's called the pink city um so it looks a certain way it's meant to wow it's meant to get when you go into for you to realize this is a very prosperous capital it's not a traditional uh capital city that's heavily fortified but it has axes um where the the king's palace is at the center right next to the the temple of govind devji who's the presiding deity and a form of krishna so it it's a city that works on several layers of religion of kingship of commerce and of prosperity and that's it stays. Why is it not heavily fortified, given that this is quite, correct me if I'm wrong, but this is quite an anarchic period in Indian history, kind of crumbling empires and competing kingdoms
你知道，这就是为什么它被称为粉红之城……所以它看起来有那么个样子，它注定要让人惊叹，当你走进去时，会让你意识到这是一个非常繁荣的首都。它不是那种防御严密、传统的首都，但它有轴线，国王的宫殿就在正中央，紧邻主神戈文德·代夫吉（Govind Devji）的庙宇——他是主神，也是黑天（Krishna）的一种化身。所以这是一个运作于宗教、王权、商业和繁荣等多重层面的城市，并且它延续了下来。鉴于这是一个相当……如果我弄错了请纠正我，但这是一个印度历史上相当无政府主义的时期，各种帝国在崩溃，竞争的王国等等，为什么它没有被重重防御呢？所以为什么他们不加固城防呢？
and so on. So why wouldn't they fortify it? Well, they're making friends with the English. They have an army of their own. And it is a walled city, so you have gates that they can seal shut. But it doesn't have, and it has forts nearby. The location of Jaipur is also such that it has mountains, there are ugly ranges that surround it, but it's not, you know, and it is just off a highway, of a very important, prosperous trade route between Agra and Ajmer.
好吧，他们在与英国人交朋友。他们有自己的军队。而且它是一座有城墙的城市，所以你有可以封死的城门。但它没有……而且它附近有堡垒。斋浦尔的地理位置也是如此，它有山脉，环绕着它的是阿拉瓦利山脉，但它不是……你知道的，而且它就在一条公路旁，一条连接阿格拉和阿杰梅尔的非常重要、繁荣的贸易路线旁。
So it is a city that is meant to be prosperous. Why would you not fortify it? Because you dealt with things diplomatically. Jaipur rulers always sort of knew which way their bread was going to be buttered. So they were very, you know, they were high ranking officials. When the Mughals were high ranking officials with um when the muhals were powerful um they made friends with the english quite quickly they had a resident in um who lived in jaipur they also in fact offered their army to um to the english at um some point and supported the the english side when the rebellion first happened okay so so you you you talk about that
所以这是一座注定要繁荣的城市。你为什么不加强防守呢？因为你们用外交手段处理事情。斋浦尔的统治者总是某种程度上知道他们的大饼哪一面会抹上黄油。所以他们非常……你知道，他们是高级官员。当莫卧儿人是高级官员时……当莫卧儿人强大时……他们很快就与英国人交朋友，他们在斋浦尔驻有一位驻扎官。事实上，他们在某个时候还向英国人提供军队，并在叛乱刚发生时支持了英国人的一方。好吧，所以你谈到了……
you talk about the english the british uh we we have two two places left on your your top 10 do the british feature are they number nine do they i think we have to talk about that at some point i was you know and i think that an interesting point for us to talk about the intervention and especially because we're talking about architecture, is that we think about the formation of a new style of architecture, which is called the Indo-Saracenic style, which we've got lots to thank Samuel Swinton Jacob, who also was in Jaipur for a long time. It's an amalgamation of various Indic elements and European taste. Right. So it's basically England meets India for architecture. And one of the most beautiful pieces of that is the Gateway of India, which is in Mumbai. And it faces west and it's sort of the gateway to the east. Because when George V came with his concert for the Delhi Darbar in 1911,
你谈到了英国人、大不列颠人……在你的前十名中还剩下两个地方。英国人上榜了吗？他们是第九名吗？我想我们在某个时候必须谈谈这个。我当时……你知道，我认为对我们来说，谈论干预的一个有趣点，特别是因为我们在谈论建筑，就是我们想到了新建筑风格的形成，被称为印度-萨拉森风格，我们要大大感谢塞缪尔·斯温顿·雅各布（Samuel Swinton Jacob），他在斋浦尔待了很长时间。它是各种印度本土元素和欧洲品味的结合。没错。所以它基本上是英国遇见印度的建筑。其中最美丽的代表之一就是孟买的印度门。它面向西方，某种程度上是通往东方的门户。因为当乔治五世为1911年的德里杜巴（Delhi Durbar）带着他的王后到来时，
they landed at Apolobandar and this gateway was then created, was constructed a few years later to commemorate that. So it's kind of like a triumphal arch, is it? It is sort of. But it's also where we said goodbye to the last of the colonisers and put them on a ship. And that's where ceremonially England left India. So that's the point. But we can't only talk about British intervention in the 20th century without talking about the partition. So when India and Pakistan become separate countries. India, Pakistan, Bangladesh in 1947.
他们登陆阿波罗班达（Apolobandar），这座宏伟的门户随后被建造，几年后建成以纪念这一事件。所以它有点像一座凯旋门，是吗？差不多是的。但它也是我们向最后一批殖民者告别并把他们送上船的地方。这就是英国人在礼仪上离开印度的地点。所以这就是那个关键点。但我们在谈论20世纪的英国干预时，绝不能不谈到印巴分治。也就是印度和巴基斯坦成为独立国家的时候。印度、巴基斯坦、孟加拉国在1947年。
So when we think about the partition, we always sort of think about the partition towards the West. So India and Pakistan, we frequently forget that there was an equally tumultuous time for when Bangladesh, which is at that time East Pakistan. So there was a country that was separated with a large landmass between it. And then Bangladesh also had its own independence.
因此，当我们想到分治时，我们总是倾向于想到西部的分治，也就是印度和巴基斯坦，我们经常忘记，对于孟加拉国（当时是东巴基斯坦）来说，也经历过同样动荡的时期。所以这是一个被大片陆地隔开的国家。然后孟加拉国也迎来了它自己的独立。
So India being part of the Indian subcontinent, getting partitioned into Pakistan, India and Bangladesh. This was such a massive tragedy that we can't quite think of a monument. In fact, it was only in 2015 that the Partition Museum was set up in Amritsar that started to gather artifacts and oral histories. It was the largest migration that happened in the history of humanity.
所以印度作为印度次大陆的一部分，被分裂成巴基斯坦、印度和孟加拉国。这是一场如此巨大的悲剧，以至于我们无法确切地想出一座纪念碑来纪念它。事实上，直到2015年，分治博物馆才在阿姆利则建立，开始收集文物和口述历史。这是人类历史上发生的最大规模的人口迁移。
Several thousand people died. I don't think that this country or any of these three countries have really addressed the trauma and have gotten over the trauma of partition. It has been 75 years. So I'd like to think about a small story called Tabatek Singh, which was written by Sadat Hassan Manto, where India and Pakistan has been, you know, the partition has happened and now they're trying to figure out what happens to the lunatics so there are two there's an asylum for the mentally challenged the lunatics and one of
成千上万的人丧生。我不认为这个国家或这三个国家中的任何一个真正解决了创伤，并且走出了分治的创伤。已经75年了。所以我很想讲一个名为《托巴·泰克·辛格》（Toba Tek Singh）的小故事，由萨达特·哈桑·曼托（Sadat Hasan Manto）所写，其中印度和巴基斯坦已经……你知道，分治已经发生，现在他们正试图弄清楚精神病人该怎么办。所以有两个……有一个关押智力障者的精神病院，精神病人们，其中一个
them wants to go back to toba teksing which is where his ancestral land was and no one could really figure out whether it was in india or was it in pakistan and it's a very touching story of a fictitious village in the middle of you know that is caught between these two countries getting so brutally sliced up without much thought um and on that simple note i think i think the only way we can deal with partition and to think about that is perhaps through literature until we get to a point where we can create a monument for it which i hope will happen where would where would such a monument be that's an interesting question will happen. Where would such a monument be? That's an interesting question.
人想要回到托巴·泰克·辛格，那是他祖先土地所在地。没有人能真正弄清楚它是在印度还是在巴基斯坦。这是一个非常感人的故事，讲的是一个虚构的村庄，位于……被这两个国家夹在中间，在没有多大思考的情况下被如此野蛮地切开……带着那个简单的感受，我想……我认为我们能够应对分治并思考它的唯一途径，也许是通过文学，直到我们达到能够为之建立一座纪念碑的地步，我希望这会发生。那样的纪念碑会在哪里？这是一个有趣的问题。会发生。那样的纪念碑会在哪里？这是一个有趣的问题。
So, you know, where would you put the monument? On the partition line? It's a very long line. The one between India and Pakistan has a barbed wire throughout. There is one entry point between the two, which is called the Vaga border, and they have ceremonial armies of both sides that have these tattoos. Yes, the guards are kind of very fancily dressed, aren't they?
所以，你知道，你会把纪念碑放在哪里？在分界线上吗？那是一条很长的线。印度和巴基斯坦之间的那条线全程都有带刺铁丝网。两者之间有一个入境点，被称为瓦加边境，双方都有进行检阅表演的仪仗队的军队。是的，卫兵的着装相当花哨，对吧？
Yes. Kind of march up to each other. Exactly. And I think that the atmosphere is us versus them, which is not how this needs to be, because ultimately we have more in common with each other than differences. needs to be because ultimately we have more in common with each other than um then yeah than differences and i think politics has really sort of stepped in um where would this be and and
是的。有点像向对方行进。没错。而且我认为那里的气氛是我们对阵他们，而事情本不该是这样的，因为最终我们彼此之间的共同点多于差异。本不该是这样的，因为最终我们彼此之间的共同点比……比是的，比差异更多，而且我认为政治真的介入了……它会在哪里？而且……
and and of course also on the on the eastern end where bangladesh was was such is is still is such an important and integral part of culture of Bengal. So the final countdown, number 10. Number 10 is a building that no longer stands. Oh, that's radical. Well, there you go. And I think that it sort of tells us the story of a very fast changing India. And I'd like to think about the Hall of Nations and the Nehru Pavilion, which was built in 1972
当然，还有在东部，孟加拉国曾经是——现在依然是——孟加拉文化中如此重要和不可分割的一部分。所以最后的倒计时，第十名。第十名是一座已经不复存在的建筑。哦，这太激进了。好吧，就是这样。而且我认为它在某种程度上向我们讲述了一个快速变化的印度的故事。我想谈谈民族大厅和尼赫鲁馆，它们建于1972年
in New Delhi again at Pragati Maidan as an exhibition space. It was the high point of brutalist architecture and built by an architect called Raj Rawal, who saw his building getting built, celebrated, won awards and then destroyed in front of him. That must have been depressing. I think it took it rather, I mean, it was anger inducing.
的新德里，再次作为展览空间建在普拉加蒂·马伊丹（Pragati Maidan）。那是野蛮主义建筑的巅峰时期，由一位名叫拉吉·雷瓦尔（Raj Rewal）的建筑师建造，他看着自己的建筑被建造、庆祝、赢得奖项，然后在他眼前被摧毁。那一定很令人沮丧。我认为它相当……我的意思是，那是激起愤怒的。
I think it was infuriating rather than depressing because nobody wanted the building to go. And essentially what they're doing is that they flattened Pragati Maidan out to create these new modern edifices and conference centers with air conditioning, which is also a sub. It basically takes on Nehruvian ideas and philosophy of what the Indian nation needs to be. And current political leaders want to rewrite history and erase it in a very specific way. So Hall of Nations is the beginning of a large-scale demolition and destruction of what secular forward-thinking free and liberal India used to be. Gosh I'm looking at the building now I'm looking at picture online it's an amazing looking building as you say it's a kind of it's a it's a it's a classic kind of post-war brutalist sort of modernist building and yet well i mean that's being very harsh tom it doesn't look like a car
我认为那是令人愤怒的，而不是令人沮丧的，因为没有人想要这座建筑消失。从本质上讲，他们做的事情是铲平了普拉加蒂·马伊丹，以建造这些带有空调的现代宏伟 edifices（建筑）和会议中心，这也是一种……它基本上承载了尼赫鲁式的思想和关于印度国家应该成为什么的哲学。而当前的政治领导人想要改写历史，并以一种非常具体的方式抹去它。因此，民族大厅是一场大规模拆除和摧毁世俗、前瞻、自由和开明的印度曾经所是的开端。天哪，我现在正在看这座建筑，我正在看网上的图片，正如你所说，这是一座令人惊叹的建筑，它是一种经典的那种战后野蛮主义风格的现代主义建筑，然而……好吧，我的意思是这话说得太严厉了，汤姆，它看起来不像一个停车场。
park i just ignored tom holland um uh and and it was demolished what 2017 2018 or something 2017 and this was still being challenged in court and overnight they brought it down um so and and is this part of a sort of backlash against yeah against that image of a of a kind of democratic secular um yes of of of narrow in india essentially because um indira gandhi took great interest in when this building was being built in 72. It is a backlash against a progressive secular India and it escalates greatly. So I have to talk about this because Kaivan Mehta who's an architectural historian and writer and a friend of mine basically says that you can sum up the you can bookend the story of modern Indian architecture between two demolitions,
我刚才忽略了汤姆·霍兰德……而且它被拆除了，是在什么时间？2017年、2018年左右？2017年。这还在法庭上受到质疑，他们在一夜之间把它推倒了……所以……这是否是对某种……是的，对那种民主、世俗的印度的形象的反弹？是的，基本上是尼赫鲁式的印度，因为英迪拉·甘地在1972年建造这座建筑时表现出了极大的兴趣。这是对一个进步的世俗印度的反弹，并且这种反弹急剧升级。所以我不得不谈论这个，因为建筑历史学家、作家兼我的朋友凯万·梅塔（Kaivan Mehta）基本上说过，你可以将现代印度建筑的故事总结并在两次拆除之间划定书挡，
one of Babri Masjid in 92 and then Holocaust in 27. So just tell us about that one, because that is, I mean, really important and a very contested site. It is a contested site. So Babar, whose garden we discussed, also allegedly built a mosque on an old temple site, which is not unheard of. I mean, you would do people have have done this, but apparently this was the site that was the birthplace of the god Ram from the Ramayana, which is ultimately a story and an important religious figure. And in 92, a Hindu right wing organization gathered several thousand people and they went off to Ayodhya where they believe that that was where Ram was born and demolished this temple. And I think that after 92, India really changed.
一次是92年的巴布里清真寺，然后是27年的大厅（Holocaust应为Hall of Nations之误）。所以给我们讲讲那件事，因为那确实是非常重要且备受争议的遗址。这是一个备受争议的遗址。所以巴布尔，我们讨论过他的花园，据称也在一个旧寺庙遗址上建造了一座清真寺，这并非闻所闻见。我的意思是，人们会……人们曾经这样做过，但显然这就是罗摩神从《罗摩衍那》中诞生的出生地，而《罗摩衍那》最终是一个故事和一个重要的宗教人物。92年，一个印度教右翼组织聚集了数千人，他们前往阿约提亚，他们认为那是罗摩诞生地的地方，并拆毁了这座寺庙。我认为在92年之后，印度真的改变了。
And the idea of secular india was challenged and we're seeing um so many years later we're seeing the uh the result of it and the prime minister narendra modi laid the foundation stone of a new temple to rama on the site what was it two years ago i think it was two years was it last year was it last year i think actually no I think it was two years ago. Was it last year? No, I think it was two years. It had to be before. I think it was two years ago. And he's a modest man because he's also named the largest cricket stadium in the world is named after him.
而世俗印度的理念受到了挑战，我们在……多年后，我们正在看到它的结果，总理纳伦德拉·莫迪在那座寺庙的遗址上为一座供奉罗摩的新寺庙奠基，那是什么时候？两年以前吗？我想那是两年前。那是去年吗？那是去年吗？我想其实不，我想那是两年前。那是去年吗？不，我想那是两年。那一定是在之前。我想那是两年前。而且他是一个谦逊的人，因为他还以自己的名字命名了世界上最大板球场。
There's a story there, isn't there, Tom? There is a story. How do you know? So England were playing India in the, I think think in was it january or february test match there in it's in amitabad and uh and and i said i tweeted um you know very modest of of the prime minister to have a the world's largest cricket stadium named after him and it got picked up by various um angry supporters of narendra modi who thought that i was spider-man so they they launched they launched a boycott of marvel films
这里有个故事，对吧，汤姆？确实有个故事。你怎么知道的？所以英格兰队当时在……我想是在一月还是二月的测试赛中在艾哈迈达巴德比赛，然后……然后我说，我在推特上说……“首相能以自己的名字命名世界上最大的板球场，真是太谦虚了。”这被纳伦德拉·莫迪的各种愤怒支持者注意到了，他们以为我是蜘蛛侠……所以他们……他们发起了对漫威电影的抵制。
a single throwaway tweet and i destroyed marvel films you see uh apana tom spends a lot of time complaining that how hard done by he is that he has the same name as Tom Holland, the real Tom Holland. But imagine being the real Tom Holland and living in fear that this elderly historian is going to get you cancelled and destroy your film career at any moment. Tom with great power comes great responsibility. You know what the great thing is? He never hears that.
一条随意的推特，我就毁了漫威电影，你看……阿帕娜，汤姆花了很多时间抱怨自己有多冤，因为他跟真实的汤姆·霍兰德——真正的汤姆·霍兰德重名。但想象一下成为真正的汤姆·霍兰德，活在恐惧中，担心这位年长的历史学家会让你“被取消”并随时毁掉你的电影生涯。汤姆，能力越大，责任越大。你知道最棒的是什么吗？他永远听不到这个。
No one ever tells him that. Well, it was a shock to realize that i'd i'd uh yeah i basically destroyed the publicity program for the new spider-man film um as a batman fan i don't mind you just stay away from bruce wayne exactly i'm not going to mention that. Apana, that was fabulous. I mean, what a sweep. So all the way from Mahenja Daro, all the way up to modern Delhi. Yeah, I don't think we've done 2,500 years or more, probably longer.
从来没有人告诉他。好吧，意识到我……我基本上毁了新蜘蛛侠电影的宣传活动时，我感到很震惊……作为蝙蝠侠粉丝，我不介意你离布鲁斯·韦恩远点。没错，我不会提那个。阿帕娜，那太精彩了。我的意思是，跨度真大。从摩亨佐-达罗一路延伸到现代德里。是的，我不认为我们讲完了2500年或更长时间，可能更久。
There's so much I've left out. There's so much we've left out. We haven't gone to Northeast. We haven't spoken about the Himalayan kingdoms. I forgot to say lots of things that I'd made notes about because it's brilliant here the clock ticking it was absolutely fantastic i mean i didn't think it was possible to do a history of india through 10 buildings in a in just with just over an hour um but it's a challenge that you've triumphantly passed so thank youiest congratulations and many, many thanks. Yeah, thank you.
我有太多东西漏掉了。我们漏掉了太多东西。我们没有去东北部。我们没有谈论喜马拉雅王国。我忘了说很多我做过笔记的事情，因为这里的时钟滴答作响太棒了，这绝对太精彩了——我的意思是，我不认为仅凭短短一个多小时就能通过10座建筑讲完印度历史……但这是一个你凯旋般通过的挑战，所以非常祝贺你，并且非常非常感谢。是的，谢谢。
Thank you. So that concludes the entire history of India. We will see you on The Rest is History next time for more historical meanderings. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。印度的全部历史到此结束。我们下次将在《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）节目中与大家见面，进行更多的历史漫游。再见。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。